okay here we go
opengl glsl
episode 7 changes since last time here
i have added another shader so of course
we got our main one right here
the cursor shader i made a few changes
to the cursor shader
it now has two radiuses that way you can
get two colors on the cursor and it's
easier to see on any
background and we added a new shader
which
i'm using the same vertex shader but i'm
using another
fragment so that's the thing i'm going
to show you
is how to start layering these and get
the effects that you want
and we're just going to keep opening up
the realm of shader possibilities one
episode at a time
we are going to be looking at a source
to pull from because
i can teach you how to let's see
i can show you the code and you'll code
for a day or i can
teach you how to copy pasta code and you
can
join the rest of us and copy past one
thing you need to know when you're
looking at examples is how to adapt it
to your code because for example
the very popular website the book of
shaders which has a lot of great
examples
but if you just copy paste stuff in it's
not going to work because there's going
to be little random errors
and i'm just going to show you how to
sort those all out and start layering
these if you want and apply any of these
examples
that you want and if you understand all
this you'll be able to basically
make shaders and layer them in any style
you can possibly imagine
well we could do any of these this one
which has this chunk of code
so if i go to my program and run it
you'll see i've got my new cursor
which now checks two radiuses so i can
get a black and white dot
that way you can see it on either
because if it was white you couldn't see
it over here if it was dark you could
see it over here
so something like this might be better
so as you can see we've implemented
their little algorithm and it works fine
but it didn't just work out of the box
so first of all i went ahead and added
that second shader and
the only thing we really need to know is
the resolution
so we're gonna set that we're gonna use
the same draw
strip same draw details we're gonna use
the same square
because why why upload more we already
have what we need but we just need to
adjust all the shader
and set it to use the right one before
drawing you go and draw order the last
thing you draw
is on top alright so you want to use the
shader you want to draw to
and then just draw so you want to have
all your variables set before the straw
because the straw
essentially you know just draws the
square
and on whatever shader it happens to be
on but this isn't touching the shader
we have to do all that ahead of time we
have some of the things in the callbacks
the main
thing we need to do is make sure we hit
use that way it's using the right one
so it'll draw and the last thing we want
to do is draw the cursor because we want
to be on
the very top so we can always see it so
there's the cursor
that i'm using the only thing it needs
is mouse pause we're going to keep these
super
clean so in the smooth frag shader this
is my test one
and we do get those results but as you
can see i have changed some things
like we don't need the mouse and time
they're not even using that i don't know
why they have these here
so delete those make sure you set the
resolution
in your code and that's not hard to do
we just have it in our callback anytime
the frame buffer
size changes we automatically update the
resolution
and we want to do it at least once
because this isn't called on launch
so in our source we do set it the very
first time
right here and you got to make sure you
use it before you set it otherwise it
won't work
yeah you just basically delete all the
stuff you don't need in these
i'm not using pi and they aren't either
so i don't know why they brought it in
here this formula is the same this is
the same
this plot worked fine so all this code
right here and right here
i didn't change i don't think at all i
just needed to get rid of the uniforms i
wasn't using get rid of pi
and of course i'm not using this up here
this gl frag color is also an old method
or maybe it's for like a mobile or
something because that doesn't work in
this if
if we like don't have this one and we
try to go gl
frag color something went terribly wrong
incompatible gl frag color is
depreciated after version 1.20
so yeah there you go it's depreciated
you'll see stuff like that
and you just gotta know to do this out
thing on more modern
so that's pretty important to catch
let's do
another one which one would be
fun i don't know let's do something that
looks a little crazier maybe
let's try one of these patterns let's
just do this one here
so there we go looks like we just need
to resolution they're not using
time so we can probably do a pretty
direct copy
pasta so not all this code is not you
know this is really i can go on here and
get it anytime right
so no need to like save every little
thing when you're just running
these demos so i'm just going to grab
all of this here and we're just going to
do a direct copy paste but we're going
to have to clean this up a ton
like first of all frag color down here
right color and anywhere that says
you resolution just needs to be
this version of it we gotta sort that
out
it looks like they got some something
here it doesn't like
okay it looks like we need to define pi
after all in this particular one
so let's go ahead and grab pi and that
should sort it out
okay and let's just see if it just runs
it does
just indeed run so you can pick through
this and walk through this step by step
to understand what's going on of course
these are all definitions of functions
up here
things that could potentially be reused
and here's their main so they
just do this little thing here
and get some of this unnecessary we we
don't need to have x
y on these or i guess we do on the frag
chord uh because it has a z and stuff
the u resolution is already an x y so
don't really need to
do that okay and then just do they
update this
st with tile and then rotate
and they do this step on it
on the last thing yeah so you can walk
through any of these like that
and figure figure it out kind of what
they're doing
and take away from it all right let's
look at a few more okay there's a lot of
different cool stuff let's try
let's try this one go no need to save
any of this stuff
let's update this to you resolution oh i
deleted too much
okay we just got to change a few things
here
and we need frag color to be on the out
here
and there you go you can see oh he's got
a mix of dot products with
random there's just random fractal of a
sign of you know some little specific
interesting so it's only pseudo-random
and there we go
so a lot of this stuff if there's
variables
you you know if you want to just keep in
mind with any of these
you're probably starting to see the
realm of shader possibilities if you're
able to grasp all this stuff
and understand what i'm doing and be
able to replicate what i'm doing
because you can you can layer and do
you know the sky's the limit at some
point of course you can look at examples
but you can always just create your own
but
using these is a great place to start to
kind of get
a grasp of of how things work
here's an example of one that was a bit
more difficult to get to run
as there were some more compatibility
things so this one would be a good one
to go over as you can see it's pretty
cool
actually displays characters i don't
know if you'll be able to see that on
the youtube video
but pretty neat effects here so i went
ahead and i uh i copied all this over
right
copied it over to to my shader and there
were some uh pretty immediate issues
this were they made a function called
care care is a reserved word so when i
tried to use care
it flagged as a reserved word thanks
to this software so i should show you
this extension i'm using because i'm
just using visual studio
and i'm using an extension called
let me find it here installed
glsl integration and it seems to do
pretty well
the only thing you can't do is you can't
you can't create these glsl
files from within here so if you go in
here and go to click add and
try to make one there there is none so
i've just been
doing it within the terminal
uh i really wish they would add it so
what i've just been
doing is launching windows terminal
going to my folder
where they exist
and do new item and then just file name
so we could do another shader we'll just
call it like background shader
we'll use this later and there it
creates then we go back into visual
studio
refresh might as well include in your
project if you
you don't like it then you can uh start
opening it up
and working on it so
just so you're aware that's how i'm
getting them in there easily
for now all right so back to the shader
care was a reserved word so it didn't
like that
through an error it's kind of hard to
detect but this syntax
analyzer did pick it up so that was cool
and it threw some error in my console as
well
and the other problems were well i just
had to update these user resolutions
these few times and this time
is an accumulated time so
we'll see that it does work here does
the thing
pretty cool
[Music]
nice little shader effect great example
and they just use all these functions
cross box grid
character bin
random random and
there's the main so it just walks
through this you can see he's even got
him sectioned off
for what he's doing pretty cool stuff
all right so that's a little more info
that i feel like will be helpful i'm
just going to show you where it's
setting the time here
so in our back to our main while loop
here
i am accumulating the time as a static
so static only declares once
uh that's why it's here and we just want
to accumulate the delta time as we go
forward every time
and we can pass that to our shader for
functions with random or sine or cosine
or
anything that wants to know or have like
an oscillating function
this accumulated time is great with that
sort of setup
and i think they were just using it to
display those numbers
okay but everything else is pretty this
pretty much the same let me know if you
have any questions down below
and here's yet another one we could
bring in that uses
assign with the runtime to do this
little effect
and i pretty much just copied all of
this over
right over here updated frag color
uh change these use view resolution and
you run time to the ones we're using
make sure we're setting those yep you're
setting the run time
we've already set the resolution it'll
auto update
and our callback of course if we ever do
change the size of our window
and yeah we're all good to run that one
and there it is
so as you can see any of these examples
that you can find on the book of shaders
you can use
and you'll be able to find these on
shader toy all over the place
and hopefully after going through this
video
and maybe through some of the previous
ones if you needed
more info you'll understand how to
actually
do that and get it working within your
code so hope this really
helps you guys out and yeah i guess we
can go from there
always give credit to the authors if
you're using
someone's work or at least make a best
effort to do so
i know some of these don't say anything
so you don't know
exactly but i guess you can at least
always reference the website if nothing
else
all right well let me know if you have
any questions
guys all right i think that's going to
do it for this episode
um let me know what you guys think if
you're able to get your shaders going if
this is helping
you know i would appreciate any feedback
that you would like to give especially
those thumbs up this
alright peace out guys see you next
episode
[Music]
a special shout out to my patrons for
making episodes
like this possible if you want to help
the channel out a lot
go sign up over there
[Music]
[Music]
you